if you have a bad attitude you will  always look ugly to other people you  have to be unselfish think about the  feelings and interest of other people a  lot more that will make you a decent  human being and more attractive to other  people nothing puts people off as much  as bad breath when you come close to  someone you talk to them and you just  smell  if your parents didn't teach you good  manners to be a gentleman  then you gotta learn it's one of the  best things that you can learn in this  world  it separates the boy from the man  all right the bonus tip now this is  super important because a lot of people  in the world  it seems like they're forgetting this  and it is so  important  because being attractive is not just  about having a good face about having an  attractive handsome face